let's get to Mike Tirico the host of
football night in America and the voice
of Notre Dame football by the way Mike
was guilty of load management when he
left ESPN to take an easier job at NBC
and easier schedule like Mike got week
days off like he doesn't have to be in
you know Manhattan Kansas on a Tuesday
night for Kansas State against Missouri
that is fabulous thank you III didn't
realize that I was a trendsetter when I
came to I also didn't realize that I was
calling to be a guest on dr. radio here
yeah mrs. fat was good I didn't right I
was not able I was traveling I'm in
Syracuse I was traveling in busy
yesterday I did not realize that the
update was not a good one kidney stone
so my apologies have you hadn't so I
have not I have not I have no stones
perspective of course of course have you
ever missed an assignment due to illness
no no I have I've been able to answer
the bell I have some sort of a streak
going that nobody's counting nobody
should count but now I've been able to
make it I've done some games where I
felt awful but I've never been in danger
whether it's travel or health of missing
a show what do you make of this load
management you know the money has gotten
so big
that instead of talking about the
players or the individuals or the badge
of honor and home phone court we're
gonna play every game like it has true
meaning it has now become protecting
investments and kind of understand it so
so let's look at let's look at the World
Series for a second the Strasburg being
held back eight years ago impact the
fact that he still is ready to go in the
biggest games in 2019 deep in October I
don't know but that whole load
management thing is a real I think it's
a real thing then and I'm glad that I'm
glad that the league is it we said you
know what guys we we can't we can't just
say you're gonna miss your national TV
games for us you've got to really be
there for the biggest games the biggest
moment so the league's gonna have to
find out a way to somehow
comfortably get between load management
and missing games on TV with superstars
well you have load management with todd
gurley this year with the rams right
somebody's playing yeah exactly and you
have load management to a lesser degree
with pitchers in baseball where they're
on a pitch count but they do show up to
pitch i I just don't know if we're gonna
get to the you know point Mike where
Kawai plays like 14 minutes and then
therefore he's satisfying everybody with
this whole load management dispute well
the conversation again has been based
around ticket buyers I buy a ticket I
want to see Dan Patrick play so if I
come see you for 14 minutes is that not
seeing you at all if I'm a ticket buyer
and it's my one trip east with the
Clippers and the Clippers are coming to
Detroit and I get to see Kawhi Leonard
for 15-20 minutes as opposed to 42 ok
that's better than not seeing them at
all for the ticket buyer but are we
really taking the interest of the ticket
buyer into consideration when we're
talking about management or are we
taking TV TV ratings and those things
which are bringing in far more money
than the Dan that's buying tickets for
the Knicks game in January well also the
collective bargaining agreement runs
through 20 23 24 so nothing's changing
with the NBA and you have a commissioner
who has basically said to the players
this is your league whereas the previous
commissioner find the San Antonio Spurs
250,000 dollars when they left all their
valuables in San Antonio for a road trip
in Miami right but what are you gonna do
you're gonna write into a new CBA you
have to play I don't know he's got a
sort he's got a sore knee but now before
the days of MRIs and you know we had
injury analysts for every sport like oh
he's got a sore knee he's not playing ok
got it
why why can't you say you know what my I
feel tweaked my Achilles I'm gonna sit
out tonight I'm not going to play the
second of the back-to-back at the end of
the day load management is
the right thing to do for having your
best players ready at the biggest
moments of the season the question to me
has become actually regular season
become watered down and is that the
ultimate sign to the league's that your
regular seasons don't matter nearly as
much as they used to
it's all gonna Mike Tirico NBC football
night in America Notre Dame play-by-play
tonight's game I mentioned the Raiders
schedule the rest of the knee on the
second half of the season Mike
I mean it's conceivable the Raiders
could end up with nine or ten game ten
wins this year which no doubt yeah would
then surprise you yeah a little bit I
mean it kind of reminds us and I'll just
be as transparent as possible my fandom
for the Raiders increased more than for
most other teams because my friendship
with John Gurdon you know you work with
a guy for seven years you certainly want
to see a route that doesn't mean you
can't go on the air and be critical of
things but you know I think I noticed
probably pretty clearly the number of
people who just cut them off the face of
the earth for the khalil Mac trade and
the Amari Cooper trade and now you look
at it right here they are who would have
thought the pick they get from the Bears
might come earlier in the draft in their
own pick you know as to my trade after
that trade was made like that's the
stupidest trade the history of the
league what are they doing and now
people don't really looks pretty good
now again it's short term answer midterm
answer and a welterweight for the final
analysis of that but they have gotten
young players to play you know in a
league where your offensive lineman can
be big they have the heaviest offensive
line of the league and a running back in
Jacobs who is the real deal and is
impacting that significantly so the fact
that car is playing well on making good
decisions is giving them a chance to
build some young guys and I thought John
said the most interesting things that I
heard in his press conference this week
when he said that car is becoming like a
coach on the field and that's when you
know that you are connecting with that
guy yeah it's very feasible they could
be nine and seven if they're nine and
seven that may be good enough in the AFC
to get to the playoffs it should be
pretty cool your colleague Tony Dungy
had some
strong words on a tweet about pass
interference and you know it's becoming
useless for coaches to bother to
challenge it I I'm at the point now if
you said we're getting rid of replay
completely I'd be fine with it
either habit to make the game better
right or don't why are why are we
worried about hurting the feelings of an
official if we overturn a pass
interference going yeah I I'm I'm with
you I've become I was so in to replate
this when we see it's wrong we can get
it right look any of us who called the
game making mistakes the play callers
the head coaches who are throwing these
challenge flags they make mistakes in
the game they put the wrong personnel in
the game they make incorrect decisions
are going for to the players throw
incomplete passes it is not a game of
perfect the only team that we're asking
to be perfect are the officials that's
impossible it is absolutely impossible
to expect perfection
so having replay in place to help them
out I've always been good with it just
really has dragged the game down I think
they you know truly did open Pandora's
box with the pass interference and you
know Tony you set with Tony for years
there's no more measured thoughtful
anything but no shoot-from-the-hip guy
Tony really makes sure that he knows his
words carry weight and the tweet me talk
about this week for Tony to say that
he's been expressing that ban since we
went to the NFL offices and looked at
this whole replay thing this year
it just felt from a coach's standpoint
like it was going to be a mess that's
exactly what it it has been a mess to
the point now that if I'm advising a
coach if I'm a GM I'm gonna sit with my
coach say well don't do it you're
costing time outs and challenges and at
the end of the day when something's at a
return rate of 9 or 10 percent it's not
worth it and unless it's financial and
this is just not worth it for coaches so
I think guys have to stop challenging
these pass interference calls I
mentioned that you do Notre Dame
football what would be a concern
considered a successful season for Notre
Dame having lost to Michigan and Georgia
yeah 1010 wins that's went out and I
don't think that's gonna be easy Duke
will still move the ball well against
this week nay
in the top 25 the Navy Notre Dame game
you know for years it's always in a
close game no matter there's this the
quality of players the athleticism or
the teams and this year Navy's really
good only one loss BC will be good and
then going to Stanford which is getting
healthier and better at the David Shaw
if they win those games which is not
easy but they'll be favored although
there'll be a 10 win team and you know
what most predictions were at the start
of the year that they'd be a 10 win team
I think people would have been ok with a
ten win season if they got blown out at
Georgia and played close at Michigan and
instead was the reverse and that's not
what everybody expected and I think that
will kind of taint the season a little
bit but 10 wins is still pretty good
seeds I think we've screwed up college
football so much where if you're not in
the playoff you had a bad year that
means 126 schools where 61 power five
schools have a bad year that's a bad
system what if we did something radical
Mike I brought this up on the show
yesterday let's say I had 512 team
conferences or let's say we did five 10
team conferences so you're playing
everybody you have a 10 game schedule
and then after that you have 16 of the
50 make the playoffs so you have 16 so
you have you know eight games there with
16 teams and and so let's have this you
know the power teams move out of their
conferences and let's just treat this as
it's big business we make it a TV show
I let the network's get together and say
just like they do the NFL you guys are
going to decide who plays who and you
know we're gonna treat this as a in
introductory offer to the NFL this is
we're gonna base this off your model
granted more teams but if I had 50 of
the best teams if you wanted to have
relegation you could have that and like
I could say to Maryland and Rutgers
you're not invited to this like you know
some of these others to Syracuse you're
not invited to this what do you think
about something is radical is that and
maybe you pay the players who were
playing in the power conferences minimum
wage or something
and they get to use their likeness and
and you treat them a little bit more
professionally than we are right now
it's all great ideas there are hundreds
there are a hundred really really good
ideas
there's not one drop of leadership and
vision to take those ideas to market and
that's the problem right now okay let me
just back up to a bigger point Dan in
all this and there are so many different
Harbaugh's plan of 13 teams in the
playoff that was interesting too there's
a whole bunch of stuff they go yeah that
could work
where is college football within the
mission of universities and colleges
around the country now I know we've
jumped the shark we're way past with
money and everything else but at the end
of the day football at Michigan has to
in some way connect with what the
president at University of Michigan is
doing and same thing at Syracuse at
Notre Dame at USC and all these schools
around the country
it can't be a regional chapter of a
semi-pro League so the leadership has to
get a system where you're paying players
for their name like this an image and
anything else that goes with it you have
to balance all of that stuff but until
any of that happens and it's not
happening at the NCAA level I don't see
any of these ideas I maybe somebody will
say okay we'll break out the playoff
contract you go from four to eight but
it's just not on the horizon this sport
is so lacking of leadership right now
and just creating bigger problems and
look this name likeness and image thing
my thought is all this legislation in
each day it might lead us quicker to the
power five schools
breaking off to a separate set of rules
because are you gonna have Dayton
football have the same name likeness and
image rules is Alabama it doesn't make
sense but that's my Mike you just took a
shot of Dayton went because I took a
shot at Syracuse no I'm just trying to
use a local tie for you just to say the
money won't be there for the Dayton
football players as it would for the
Alabama football player so why should
they be one element they're not Division
one games on Division one and by the way
almost five and three this year I won't
bring up Syracuse's record we're a three
win team at the moment that's good but
they're NCAA rules her name like this an
image so
how can you do at the FCS level the same
thing that you want to do at Notre Dame
and it's just a different subset the
fact that FBS schools play FCS schools
and it counts is like the twins playing
a triple-a team in the games count if
that disrespecting FCS there are good
teams better than some FBS teams but
it's not the same set of rules so the
whole system the entire sport needs a
complete overhaul and there's nobody
standing up to say let's do this in any
leadership place and that's why this is
just gonna be one more band-aid on top
of another bad dated we're not going to
a good place now now state legislatures
are involved and then the federal
government to get involved and then I
wish you well what do you have Sunday
night Cowboys and Vikings ooh yeah good
game hey look every game in the NFC
matters wild cards are gonna be tight
tight week 16 and 17 so important game
both ways but Cowboys is still like that
that's gold that's TV gold right that's
guaranteed over over the Steelers over
the Packers yeah yeah look at the Monday
Night Football rate I think Monday night
had its best audience of the year and
they were playing the Giants but just
it's just a cowboy factor there's still
magic of seeing Jerry after a touchdown
or a turnover and DAC and Amar'e and if
they're soap operas are still level
three soap operas it's Jason Garrett in
trouble it's it's October let's settle
down
it's they are fun they're great for
football they're great for the sport
always have been if they clearly still
are alright I got an idea for you okay
okay this is a stat graphic okay Kirk
Cousins yeah as the Sun starts to go
down and then the change so you had the
Sun going down and then his stats come
up on the screen and then you see that
he's not
mr. TV no load management for me money
no load management for me even a man
fighting his own stones can come up with
creativity you are you're one of a car
Thank You bud good to talk to you Mikey
same here but that's Mike Tirico for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]